ted thank you tonight prices at the palm
still impacting our wallet many hoping
for some relief yeah and according to
aaa nevadans are paying on average 5.23
a gallon about 10 cents more from last
week christian kosovis joining us now
with a look at how the hike is hurting
everyone across the board hi christian
that's right guys well drivers usually
driving with diesel can't even catch a
break now according to aaa check this
out nevadans are paying right now on
average
fifty three cents per gallon now a month
ago that number dropping to about five
dollars and twenty nine cents now if we
roll things back about it a year ago
today we were uh nevadans were paying
about three dollars and forty five cents
per gallon of diesel now some truck
drivers doing what they can to survive
it has its ups and downs but when the
gas prices hit you know it kind of
slowed my business down we met cedric
johnson at a las vegas truck stop as he
got ready to hit the road to phoenix he
says high diesel gas prices are a big
factor for the work that he gets you
know how far i go and you know what type
of loads i pick up you know whether it's
heavy or light and then just go from
there today his gas bill he says is high
i spent about between
750
and 800 between 750-800
that's one way compared to filling up
his tank in california or arizona he
completes an average of three trips per
week and barely breaks even although he
has found ways to save like the pilot
you know they give you 20 20 i believe
15 to 20 cents off per gallon which is
pretty good you know
and you know like i said i just try to
stay you know as local as i can i try
not to go too far as gas prices continue
to go up including diesel consumers are
forced to pay the difference for goods
transported in trucks trains or ships
johnson says he's trying to survive
after taking a leap of faith from the
pandemic to become his own boss with me
being an owner operator i mean
everything is coming out of my pocket is
now you know five plus and in california
it's like six six plus owner operators
as far as myself
are really feeling it
well johnson says another punch will be
the increase in gas prices for the
summer season christian cassette is live
local now